one of the things i know i've told
people on my team
is to go through the process
of trying to look at what you're doing
from your audiences
or stakeholders perspective three times
which may not even be enough
and try and like strip away the data
scientist
specific piece of it and get it closer
and closer to
you know someone who's arriving at this
meeting and is going to pay attention
for maybe 15 minutes and has
problems they want to solve what do they
want to hear about how can they consume
that and what do they
not want to hear about
and so that process of like do that
three times like present to other people
on your team present to other people in
the company and get feedback
it's uh it's really hard to get in just
one step of i did this and now i'm going
to try and present it
to that the right level of
communication simplicity and
audience awareness so that's
one thing and then i think just getting
exposure
exposure to other teams and other parts
of the business wherever possible
really helps build
empathy and understanding for other
people's
perspectives so whether that's like
getting out into the field
or sitting in on other teams
discussions just generally trying to
understand where everyone else is
coming from um and what kinds of
pressures and challenges they're dealing
with is really helpful
not just for um not just for formulating
what problems we solve and having
kind of contextual awareness of building
models and things but in communicating
with people also